Hey, what's going on? It's Bill Burr and It's time for the Thursday afternoon.
Just before Friday. Monday morning podcast.
Yeah. Or
just checking in on. Yeah. What's going on? Whoa, whoa. Jesus. The levels,
the levels. What happened? You know,
one of these days I'm actually going to have like a little podcast room.
I mean they have one in the all things, comedy studios.
I just never get over there.
I never get over there cause I'm a working stiff.
I go to work every day.
I'm in a job in fucking 20 years and I'll tell you right now I didn't miss it.
Oh I didn't miss getting in the fucking car bump up a but dude Lou to right.
I don't think I'll ever get over how fucking awful the drivers are out here.
I just, their complete lack of sense of where their fucking car is.
If one more comment in front of me is going to make a left and they just sitting
right in the middle of the link, get over to the fucking left.
So everyone around you can go around you.
I know you've been the guy trying to get around the person.
Did you learn nothing? Obviously you did. Obviously it didn't.
I try, I play like a little game. Like how long can I go before I lose my shit?
Like I could literally just make a great youtube show. If I just put a,
I don't know about great,
but it'd be interesting if I just put a GoPro up on the inside of my fucking
Prius Dashboard and just, just maybe just call the show. How long can he go?
Right. It'd be like every day. Okay.
Bill drives from here to here. Right? I might do this.
Bill drives from here to here, whatever. It's you say the distance and then you,
you guys can gamble.
It's like fantasy football without the fucking football and you,
the LVL of an over under how many times is he gonna snap?
Um, or whatnot, you know, already forget the name of the show,
but whatever it could be. It could be interesting to me.
I don't know if it's interesting to Yo and you know,
carbon seen lately that I'm actually, I like,
is that Volkswagen GTI?
They brought the thing back and every time I peek in creepily into the fucking
cars as I walked by, I see that they still have the stick shift.
There's not a lot of those left. That's a great car. Good Bang for the buck,
right? All Frugal freckles yet,
God forbid he buys himself something flashy. Um,
I swear to God, you think that I lived in the depression,
always hear like my parents how fucking frugal their grandparents were.
I think it rubbed off on them and then it's on to me.
I'll buy my fucking wife anything, but I won't buy myself shit.
I just won't do what I always get there. I'm going to buy it,
I'm going to do it. And I go, Hey, what the fuck am I going to do?
And then I'm going to have it and then what they want am I going to do with it?
Then it's just going to be sitting there.
It's either going to get dust on it or someone's going to drive into the fucking
side of it. What's the point? You know,
a very wise man once told me, you know what true wealth is walking into,
into a mall, being able to buy anything and then you don't,
and it goes into your walkout and you have the freedom of that lack of debt.
And I'll tell you, it's fucking addicting. It really is.
Although recently somebody just gave me a fucking wireless breaker and I was
freaking out about the thing. I actually sinked up my phone to it.
I couldn't believe how great it sounded.
And I was gonna add it into my gym of course, until uh,
the lovely Nia heard out good at sound, she was like, touch it, be on the house.
We should both use it. So I, you know, I got fucked out of that thing,
but, um, so I'm like an ass. So I think it might even told this story on Monday.
I was actually texting people, telling them, you got to get a wireless speaker.
The sing is fucking incredible. And every one of my friends wrote me back. Like,
ah, yeah, I kind of bought one of those like five years ago. And it was like,
oh, you know, just, you know, case Shan, you know,
I just, uh, figured it out. You know what?
I'm actually recording this cause my wife's still sleeping and it's her
birthday. Bateau doodle [inaudible] right. So I don't want to wake her up,
which I probably already did. So, um, I'm in this, uh, how I'm gonna, I'm gonna,
I'm in this room and I have, these are all my old drum.
I can't even say DVDs. Most. Most of these are VHS I bought.
I bought like every instructional fucking video you could, the classic,
I got the Tommy Aldridge rock drums soloing and double bass workout.
I got another one, double bass drumming. I don't even know who that is.
I don't even play double bass. Uh,
Kenny aronoffs power workout number one and two with the workout booklet.
I got the Carter Beauford one that's a DVD. I get Steve,
get up close. I got the funky drummers who have the
David Garibaldi Tower of groove all Mara Keem let it flow.
The modern drummer festival year 2000.
This is all just drum geek shit. I got fucking everybody. Keith Carlock,
Dennis Chambers, the Drum Basadur, right?
The drummer collective 25th. Oh. Then I got Steve.
Glad up close on DVD and in session two copies of that for some fucking reason.
Jesus Christ. Look at all these fucking things. Modern drummer.
What year is that? One, 2008. That's not bad. John Blackwell. Greg Bissonette,
I got, I got them all. I got them off. Dave Weckl.
Okay.
Victor Wooten and Carter Beauford. Zoro I got,
I got them all. Got them all. God knows it didn't help, but you know what?
I bought them off. Oh, I bought 'em all. Um, by the way.
So recently I said to a buddy of mine, um, I was like, you know what?
I think the best guitar sound,
my favorite guitar sound I ever heard on an ACDC album was the,
for those about to rock album. He was like, really?
I never listened to that fucking thing, but blah, blah, blah, blah, blah.
And uh, that was the album that came out right after the back and black album,
which sold, you know, like fucking 90 zillion copies. So they get,
there's nowhere to go after that. Right?
There's no fucking way to go after that. So no matter what you come up with,
people are gonna say it's a flop. But I fucking love that album. And um,
and it just so happened Dean del Ray from, um,
oh Jesus,
I just spaced on the name of his fuck podcast for those about to talk.
No, let there be talk. And it was one of the ACDC alums.
Um, he, uh,
he sent me this great article on the making of the back and black album and I,
it was so crazy to me because I was old enough when that came out.
Like I remember when back in black came out,
I was 12 years old and then dirty deeds came out,
which was actually a bond, Scott. And he was already dead obviously,
and then they released that for whatever fucking reason.
Now looking at it, um,
which is crazy because Bon Scott dies right after the highway to hell album and
ACDC gets Brian Johnson and it's literally like,
if this guy doesn't make it, they go right back to playing pubs.
Who knows what the fuck happens. The band's over.
And they ended up having one of the, you know,
just basically eight back and black album sold. Um,
more copies than anything probably other than like Michael Jackson thriller or
Pink Floyd, the wall, not the wall, the dark side of the moon, whatever. Jesus.
Bill, get to the point here.
So you think the last thing you would fucking do is after you've established a
new fucking singer is then put out some old shit by the last guy who's now dead.
So the, the fucking new guy has to reestablish himself all over again. Um,
I never really even thought about that cause I just loved everything that they
did. And I remember, um,
being confused of why back in black, the back,
the guy on back in black sounded so different on dirty dates cause there was no
fucking information back then.
There was no internet shit just came out and you're like, oh, another ac DCM.
Then you'd put it on, you had no fucking idea, especially at 12.
I didn't know what the fuck was going on.
And then for those about the rock came out after that.
So this is great article talking about all of that and how that was Atlantic
records,
they thought AC DC was a flash in the pan and they thought the back and black
album, I don't know how the fuck you make an album is great as that.
You don't think that they have anything else left in the tank.
So they were like going,
well let's strike while the irons hot and they fucking put out dirty deeds and
the band didn't want them to. It had been released, I believe in Australia.
And then also in a and m England under a different fucking name.
I forget. I used to know all this shit when I was super fucking ACDC nerd. Um,
and also I hadn't talked on a cell phone for 20 years, so I had a memory. Um,
but then for those, about the rock came out,
I remember this fucking kid in gym class going, look, you newish,
you show them those boats rock. I was like, I haven't heard yet.
You just fucking shocks. I remember thinking like, what do you mean?
I don't think it sucks. I like that album. You know,
I like the first song and I find I never bought the album because he told me
that it sucked until years later I found just like,
fuck this man, I'm going to buy this album. And um,
to this day I still listen to that. Like when I go downstairs, you know,
walk right into my garage with my fucking gym. Right. Which is so awesome.
That's what I play. That's what I've been playing lately. And uh,
it's fucking hilarious. Like I literally, when I go to my gym now,
which is just like back in the day when I lived in my parents house and I just
would go down to the basement and I would play either appetite for destruction,
the whole fucking album. I used to play that whole album, lift to it,
and then I would go play drums to it or whatever, whatever album I was into,
I would lift weights to the entire album and then I would play drums to it or
try to. So I'm in the middle of doing that yet. Uh,
yesterday it was fucking a, you know, venician day,
your favorite fucking day, the only only fucking exercise.
You really keep track of what weight you putting up. And I had a flashback.
I fucking, I was half asleep, you know, right in all day.
And I'd try to get to workout in before I go into the writers room so I don't
become a fucking fat pasty fuck. And um,
so I had the 40 fives on either side, right. I do a set and then I was going,
I thought I grabbed tens right to just do one 55 and I w I wasn't paying
attention and I picked it up off the Barnes like, wow,
this feels really fucking heavy.
And I just brought it down on my chest and I was like,
and I couldn't lift it back. I grabbed 25, so I went up to one 85, which,
you know, I mean, when you get, that's a lot of weight for me. I mean,
that's more than what I waste. So I'm sitting there,
I get it on my chest and knee is asleep and I'm going near B and I can't get it
off.
It took me back to the days when I was living at home with my parents and I'd be
gone, mom, mom, and she'd be gone.
I'll be down there and I'd be down there like with fucking like, you know,
one 85 one 90 sitting on my fucking pacey chest trying to get it off 200 pounds.
It was always like, I was always trying to get up to that, but I was just,
I'm a middleweight man. Like seriously, if I wasn't such a fucking booze bag,
like I probably should wait like between one 61 65 instead of a buck 80 but that
lasts 50 pounds up telling you is nothing but Scotch and pizza. Right.
So I got this shit sitting on my chest and I'm like, holy fuck I,
I didn't have the clips on it, but I didn't want to fucking,
I didn't want to dump it off to one side.
You know when you do that and then you get fucking whipped around because a,
I was worried I was gonna fly into the mirror, right.
So I ended up having to roll the thing down, like back in the day.
And there's that brutal part where it gets right on your fucking hip bones and
then you gotta do the little up and over your junk.
And before all the weight rests on your fucking thighs.
Oh, it's the worst.
I hadn't done it so long and the closer it gets to your knee caps and then
finally you got to do that fucking thing where it just,
it just scraped your knee bones and then boom hits the floor. And um, yeah,
I did that as a a 47, soon to be 48 year old man.
That was my fucking yesterday morning. I love the hole in this wall.
Isn't that great?
You know why I liked the hole in the wall and I'm looking at right now is I can
see the copper fucking pipe that I had put in there.
Finally going to get this fixed, get this fucking room painted. Then that's it.
Then all I need to do is Redo the kitchen and then it's a brand new fucking
house. It's the house that it should have been that it used to be, you know,
then I'll probably put it on the market and a,
I'll take it for like a $400,000 loss.
Ooh.
Buy a house. People. It's a great investment. I'm such a fucking Weirdo.
Even though I'm going to lose money on this fucking house. I actually,
well I guess, uh, I guess I may never sell it. I won't. Right. Um,
what I like about it, what I did to the house is I actually,
this is going to be weird.
I feel like a sense of responsibility when you own a fucking house,
you know that the next person should get it and they should be like,
you know what an appreciate the lead of the last guy he pocket did this. Right.
He kept it nice. You know, you ever see an old guy with an old car,
but he kept it nice, still get it nice and fucking waxed and all of that shit.
And everybody goes, okay, that guy, like I was raised fucking right. You know,
that's what I'm hoping the next people are gonna think. But I know they're not,
they're just gonna come in here and do fucking blow and fuck hookers and you
have some goddamn kid running around with a fucking crayon and ruin all this
shit. Not even appreciate that.
I got the fucking door locks fixed and there's a little skeleton key in there
and you can lock all the doors like it's 19, 23. Again,
you know when you're going to have Charlie Chaplin over for some fucking non
genetically altered fucking horse meat burgers or whatever the fuck they used to
eat back then. Um, anyways, uh,
I need to get glasses. By the way. I gotta do that. Um,
I get to get my physical here so I can, uh,
I told you what the pilot's license every two years. I got it. I don't,
I don't think I'm going to pass the eye exam. And, um,
I was actually thinking about it like, uh, I could probably get away with it,
you know, I could probably one more time get away with it. And it's like, Bill,
do you really want to be like 1300 feet off the ground?
Getting Away with something? What are we doing here?
Why don't we try to get our fucking priorities straight, you know,
and make it fucking happen. Um, so I'm going to go get some and uh,
I know I'm going to look like a fucking sex offender.
So already gonna be funny to me. Um, actually you know something,
you know who did a joke like that was a Ari Shaffir so I got to give them credit
even though that's, um,
that might have been like lifting a joke that that's exactly what I would look
like.
But then it just made me flash back when he shaved his head and he was talking
about, hey, he couldn't have his glasses on.
Cause if you put him on and he looked like a sex offender, see that?
That right there is why I don't like watching other people's acts because the
shit just rolls around in your head and all of a sudden it just puts one in the
chamber. Um, anyways,
plowing ahead here. Uh, did anybody, uh,
anybody listen to the Michael Rappaport podcasts? I am Rapaport.
I called in to his podcast and we talked some sports and uh,
you know, he ended up wanting to put money on game seven. All right.
Bet a steak dinner. And um,
I took OKC and he took, uh, the warriors. I forget what the spread was,
but I just didn't feel like it was enough points.
I didn't feel comfortable with the bed.
It was like seven or something like that. I just said, you know what?
Bump it up to eight. You bump it up to eight, you give me eight points,
I'll take OKC. And he goes, all right, you know, bet. And you know what?
Bam right there, Fred fucking eight points.
It's exactly what the spread was, dude, I fucking called it.
So we didn't work out what a, what a what a push would be like, who would win?
So now we're a, we've bet the NBA finals, I took the Cleveland Cavaliers,
he took, uh, the Golden State Warriors. So it's a,
can't even say double or nothing cause nobody won the first one. So, um,
I don't know. That's always a great bet. You know, steak dinner.
It's not going to break the bank and then you get to go out and, uh,
even though it's costing you money, you get a stake out of it, right?
Some bad when you say, alright, let's plow ahead here.
Let's do a little bit of a read some advertising here for this lovely Thursday
afternoon. Ruby, the receptionist, okay,
this is gonna be some fucking robot,
like the baseball kid moment at the baseball kid,
the baseball kid at baseball's words you own to do the baseball kid,
we'll phd you. And it was literally like the, for the only child,
everybody always said it's for the kid with no friends. It's no,
it's for the kid with no siblings. Cause even the kid with no siblings, I mean,
no friends still had, still had a brother or sister. It'd be like, Hey,
could you, uh, if everybody kind of hates me at school,
could you earth throw the barber? Is there anything worse than that?
How mean kids are to each other? It's fucking brutal. But I'll tell you,
you know what? It ends up producing some great comedians. You know,
some psychos driven to fucking take their app to the next level.
I'm going to show them. I'm going to show,
okay, I'm going to go to the reunion ever. It's going to be, I'm sorry.
We pushed it down. Nobody gives a fuck. All right, Ruby, the receptionist,
this podcast is brought to you by, no, it isn't.
It's not brought to you by ruby receptionists. You fucking entitled. Cons.
Start over at Ruby. The receptionist,
ruby the receptionist is a virtual receptionist service.
That means you forward your existing business phone number to Ruby's friendly
receptionist in Portland, Oregon. Who Answer on your behalf?
Portland. Okay. Smart Technology shows.
Uh Oh God. Are they all dressed like Edith? Wharton.
Smart Technology shows them details about your business and your callers even
before picking up the phone. So they sound like they're right in your office.
Plus you can provide detailed call handling instructions for everyone in your
business as well as yeah, for different types of callers, take a message,
send them to voicemail or put them through to yourself.
Best of all, why is my stomach grumbling best of all?
It just had a couple of waffles. Uh, best of all, Ruby, the receptionist, uh,
ruby receptionist care about connecting with your crawlers and making their day
while you're making your business look good. Customers agree as they,
you repeatedly rate ruby service as five star on Yelp.
Can you guys hear that? Yeah,
that I just put the mic up to customers. There it is.
It's grumbling. I just said fucking two waffles.
And some Bacon customers agree as they repeatedly rate ruby service as five
stars on Yelp. With Ruby receptionists,
it's like having a model full time employee for a fraction of the cost.
Plus they are, they're never sick on vacation or out to lunch.
Get started today and call
ruby.com/burr and get free activation on $95 value.
That's call ruby.com/bar you know,
it's another thing too is she can't fuck them either.
So you won't ruin your marriage. You know, no matter how hot they sound,
they're all the way up in Portland. You know,
and who's going to go up there unless you live in Eugene.
Um, track our smart phone,
smart cass mad homes technology has made everything smashed.
Losing your stuff is still still make smapp people feel stupid.
Feel wicked stupid dude. Um,
track or makes losing things a thing of the past track or is a coin size device
that locates misplaced keys, wallets, bags, computers, uh,
Snowden. Anything in seconds, just pair tracker to your smart phone,
smartphone and attach it to anything and find its precise location with the tap
of a button. It's that easy. Lose your phone, press the button on track or,
and your phone rings even when it's on silent.
Isn't that creepy with over 1.5 million devices?
Tracker has the largest crowd gps network in the world.
So your last item and show last items shows up on a map.
Even if it's miles away, never lose anything. Again,
track or listen listeners to this show,
get a special discount offer of 30% off your entire order.
Go to the spelled t h e track,
r t r a C K e r.com and enter the Promo code berth.
The hardest thing you'll ever have to do is find their website.
Go to tracker.com right now and enter the Promo Code Bar for 30% off your entire
order. Again, the tracker.com
flash berm, promocode, Burt, whatever. Alright, is it not slash bar? No,
the tracker.com Promo Code Bird. That's what it is. All right, and finally,
lastly, but certainly not leastly.
We don't anyone of these advertisers to feel left out that anyone is more
important than the others.
It's just at some point someone has to bring up the rear. Look at it this way,
you're batting cleanup, Boll and branch. Everybody sounds like a steak house,
but it isn't, as you said, to improve yourself. This is,
there is one simple thing you can do every day to help you be your best in every
situation. And that's getting a good night's sleep. Isn't that the truth?
Boll and branch delivers the rest you need wrapped up in there.
Super comfortable luxury linens and they do it right there.
First betting company to be the first bedding company to be fair trade
certified, which means that your sheets come from the work of happy hands,
not from sweatshops. You know something? I wish more companies did this man,
you know,
considering everything I made I'm wearing was fucking sewn together at three in
the morning. But God knows who um,
and beginning and beautiful packaging made entirely from recycled and
sustainable materials like this company,
they've got their head screwed on straight. You know what?
Everybody's got a weakness. I wonder what they're doing. I wonder what it is.
The probably smoking meth. I'm next. Please mention that.
I'm going to mention it if you give it to me. All right, let's get through this.
You can only get their sheets in one place.
That's Boll and branch.com where you know you're paying for quality and not
department store overhead.
You're getting thousand dollars sheets for just a couple of hundred bucks.
Go online to bolt, that's B, O, l, l,
n branch.com like cliff, like tree branch,
and they'll let you try them risk-free for 30 nights.
You can't lay on them during the day, but 30 nights you got them.
If you don't love them, you can send them back.
You've got nothing to lose and it gets even better.
Go to Bolin branch.com today for 20% off your entire order sheets, towels,
blankets, do VA covers everything plus free shipping and all their products come
beautifully packaged in their signature boxes.
Go to bolden branch.com today for 20% off your entire order and use the Promo
Code Bar. That's Boll and branch.com Promo Code Bar.
Hi Boll and branch.com Promo Code Burr. All right,
my the only one who kind of looked at Ruby, the receptionist said,
I know just the way they word that and now you don't. You know,
for a fraction of the cost, you can underpay these fucking people. You know,
I like a fucking receptionist and you know,
I might be old school, I might be sexiest, sexiest, as sexy.
Sexist is what I'm trying to say. I liked the reception,
the hoary or the better, as long as they get the job done, it's not that better.
When you walked in, right? And there was some fucking, you know,
chick walking around with fucking fuck me pumps on,
you know,
if she looks good and all these God damn feminists out there that sit there and
they flip out and they act like every fucking beautiful woman out there would be
a chemist if it wasn't for men,
like make you know some of 'em they're putting their best foot forward.
Jesus Christ. What do you think we have remote controls for?
Because no one wants to get up off the couch and God damn it,
if a woman is born beautiful and all she's gotta do is walk around with her ass,
jacked up in a tits, jiggling around a fucking office. And next thing you know,
she's got a beautiful home to go home to, right?
Cause some rich guy goes in there, go, you know what?
I'd like to stick my billionaire Dick between those tits and well,
what's wrong with that? And then meanwhile, so fucking, you know,
half for Leprechaun jerk off like me can come in and I got something to look,
look at while I'm waiting for the fucking doctor to finally come in and figure
out what's wrong with my spinal cord. What is wrong with dad?
What is wrong with that? You homely fucking haters of beautiful women.
God bless him. God bless them for just showing up and looking good. You know,
giving you some to rub one out too. You know,
everything serves a purpose in life. Like right now,
if you some broad and you listen to me,
I'm probably motivate you to go write some paper maybe in Portland, you know,
we all serve a fucking purpose.
Can't we just let the whores be whores? You know,
there's a reason that word exists. All right. And I, you know,
I guess because men are running shit that sometimes there's fewer options,
but give me a fucking break. You know what I mean?
It would be great if everything was lip like even, you know what I mean?
Everything was just fair and the best got the fucking job right.
But that's never going to happen because we're human beings.
And that includes those feminists who don't want it equal.
They just want it better for them. Right.
That's why they're only talking about women.
They're not talking about the poor kids that so together their bedsheets,
unless they go to boll and branch. Oh, that little call back to the advertising.
All right, let's just say it was free, not free.
Let's just say everything was fucking even,
are you really going to tell me that they wouldn't still be that chick running
around? Just fucking blowing people cause she enjoys it. Why can't she just,
you know, why can't she have a good time? Don't you judge a you home?
We hate her of a cock. Gobbler Huh?
I don't even want, I'm talking about, I'm just filling up time here.
Oh would you look at it at 26 minutes in 26 minutes in and I'm for my lady to
wake up. I've got a couple of nice gifts. Couple of right there.
Fred's Huh?
I'm a big fan of buying your wife like something that she wears,
you know, cause the more shit that you buy her that she wears clothes,
necklace, jewelry, any of that bullshit, the more that shit that you buy her,
the bigger chance she's going to be wearing it.
When she's bitching at you about something and all you do is you just put your
eyebrows up and then she's ran, ran, ran,
you just point to whatever you bought or you know,
stop some right in their tracks.
Well let's say you've got something on your wrist. Said, what is that?
And then the first they looking at what did I, did I put my arm in something?
No, no, no. Right there on your wrist. And then they just looked down.
Then they realize what you're doing. Then they just go out, fuck you.
And then you laugh and it's over. You laugh and then it's over. Right.
And you go over and you do a couple of Jaeger bombs, Albert, your fucking bar.
You'd be like, what? Man? You're drinking too much.
And then you point to their airings.
What if there's something on the side of the fence? Oh fuck you. Yeah,
it's great.
And then you get another round telling you all you assholes who are hiding your
booze in the back of your fucking toilet. Just ease off on the booze.
Buy Your wife a couple of things that she's going to be wearing.
Then you can drink in public like a man. You know Jesus fucking Christ.
Okay
Jesus. You know, imagine being that big of a drunk that you're actually like,
cause that's so fucking cliched. You know it's also brilliant too.
You know the first guy who did it cause he keeping it nice and chilled,
right? Taking it up the back.
Oh God. What a fucking, how unhappy is that God damn life.
Your wife just sitting there fucking yammering at you and you're going,
oh my God, this I, I don't think I can get through this. You know?
And she thinks she gets some sort of weak bladder. You just keep going in there,
you know, taking the little cork out,
taking a swig like a fuck it pirate
mean you got to flush the toilet like you dropped another dose. Oh my God.
I guess if you're an alcoholic you probably eat better, right?
You just keep eating veggies all the time.
So no one will get wise to the fact he had a little bottle back there.
I really don't even know what I'm talking about right now.
All I know is that the Pittsburgh Penguins,
the knee breakers, they're up, uh, two games to none.
What a fucking story that's going to be if they win. I'm tell you right now,
I don't know what the fucking odds were, but nobody,
people even in Pittsburgh didn't even put money down. And if they did,
they just did it because they loved their team.
But nobody at the beginning of this season,
there's no Pittsburgh penguin fan that said, you know what,
the penguins are going to make the fucking Stanley Cup final.
They're gonna make the finals, they're gonna make the Stanley Cup final. And,
uh, they're going to go up two games to none.
There's not one person that one parami a Panini,
whatever the fuck that place is called,
where they stick the French fries and like fucking your breakfast and your
dinner in between those buns. Right? There's nobody standing down there,
right. With the giant fucking back roll. You know,
Pittsburgh's big on that man.
People guys sit down at bars and you just got like those just softball size
chunk of fucking Lard, you know, just protect. It's like the,
the kidney airbag, right?
It's sitting there. Right. And you know, that's not a set,
it's a fucking trifecta. Cause once you got those,
then you got the fucking bud crack and that's what you got.
That's what you see when you go into those fucking places. And you know,
Pittsburgh's not the only place that goes, hey, you know,
we all like burgers and fries. You know, we all like a sandwich with fries,
but it isn't an annoying that, you know,
you got to hold the sandwich in one hand and then pick up the fries with the
other.
Wouldn't it be great if you could just have them all between the sandwich.
You know what I mean?
So you can just shove it down your fucking throat as you dial in another fucking
pizza. You know, calling up dominoes as some shit.
They're not the only ones who do that. There's a,
there's a bunch of fucking places around the country that do it.
And I'm telling you, whenever you go into those places, it's, I'm telling you,
you see the kidney airbags,
those giant fucking hamhocks just hanging. I mean, literally like,
I swear to God, people in Pittsburgh, I'm telling you, like 40% of them,
you could literally take an aluminum bat and just fucking whacked him in the
right in that back fat.
And it would take them like probably a good 30 seconds before they turned around
you. They felt it in eight seconds, but they got to get all,
they got to get the momentum to turn that torso around.
And all you gotta do is just stay outside of their meat hooks. But it's,
cause I'm telling you, if anybody from Pittsburgh gets their hands on you,
it's fucking over.
They're going to pull you into that mass and you're just going to be
claustrophobic, like remember word just yet. You're going to,
they're going to drown you and their fucking man tits. I'm telling you,
the army tourists die a year just accidentally.
They go to Pittsburgh for a fucking pirate game where the most beautiful
stadiums ever, right?
One of those fucking ham hock Pittsburgh fatties gets a little too drunk.
They lose their fucking equilibrium and they just fall. You know,
you ever see like when they go to detonate a building and it doesn't fall right
or some jerk off goes to cut down a train and lands on his own house.
That's what happens except the houses a tourist and the trees have fatty from
Pittsburgh. All right. I don't know what I'm saying. All right, that's it.
That's the podcast. Just checking in on you. All right, here's some music. Uh,
enjoy this. I don't know what the fuck it's going to be.
I don't handle this aspect of it.
And then we then you can listen to the last half hour, be a,
some podcasts from a year ago and buy from the same Frankel Douche that you're
listening to now. You have been listening to the Thursday afternoon,
Monday morning podcast just before Friday.
I hope you all have a wonderful weekend. You [inaudible] and um,
I hope San Jose wins. Not The whole series. I just, I just need seven games.
This is nothing against Pittsburgh. I was just breaking your balls.
It's just that this is when like the panic, my sports panic starts settling in.
Like, Oh my God, the hockey season's over and VA's over.
It's just baseball, baseball, baseball.
That dog days of fucking baseball on the red sox are in first place too.
I love to get into it. Oh by the way, month of May,
the cigar count all freckles. I only had one.
I only had one last three months and I said I'd have two a month this year.
I had two in January, two in February, two and a half. Cause one wasn't lit.
Right. But I don't count that one. Fuck that. Two. Two had one in March,
one in April, one in May. So that's one, two, three, four, five, six, seven.
I like that. That's not bad. Now we're not going to discuss my drinking though,
cause I'll tell you it's off the fucking
see you.
[inaudible]
the
[inaudible] this Guy
[inaudible] [inaudible] haven't yet
going on. It's still birth.
It's the Monday morning podcast that I am doing on Tuesday at 1120 in the
morning, east coast time.
Fucking believe that we're going gonna be slipping. You know,
no excuse. Actually, I do have an excuse.
It was my girlfriend's birthday yesterday. So, uh,
I was being a great boyfriend.
Paying attention to her and someone had to suffer. You know what I mean?
Like a threesome.
Someone always feels left out no matter how much you try to pay attention.
My kid and I never had a threesome before. I couldn't have one once.
I think twice.
The first time I didn't realize that it was going down.
I was so young and stupid. I was actually there and I was thinking,
why won't her roommate leave? You know, the fuck.
And it wasn't until like literally seven years later I went, oh, wait a minute.
She wasn't leaving cause fuck. And then the other time,
uh, I was right there on the table. And, uh,
one girl was absolutely gorgeous and the other one,
uh, was not gorgeous. Let's put it that way,
was so not gorgeous that she eclipsed the beauty of the other one.
You know, so, so then you go, hey,
you learned something about me right off the damn bat. Okay.
Oh, what does, this is what we're gonna do,
do this week on the podcast if you guys are new to this shit, a new to my page,
um, I do one of these every goddamn week.
And people asked me questions and I try to answer them. And other than that,
I babble.
I give you information about my life and, uh,
and that's it. I'm fucking, I have it all right. I drank last night. Okay.
I was celebrating conviction,
went to this God damn restaurant in New York and went to Bible.
And I'm big fan of Mario Batali, but I liked Lupa better.
Baba was just too, it was too, uh,
what, uh, my talent was not sophisticated enough. Right.
I'll take the blame chooses Christ.
It was like regular dishes with shit you'd never eat.
I had beef cheek, Ravioli. Yeah.
Once you fucking take that in for a minute. All right. And they had, you know,
they had like pheasants face fucking Lasagna.
It was always like half what you would heard of like goose liver,
a fucking souffle. So I don't know.
It was, they was good, but a Lupa is the shit.
That's the one that I liked. That's got like a fucking, you know,
regular animals,
body parts that you eat mixed in with fucking a Rigatoni.
Oh, what the fuck are you going to do? You know? Yeah. You try shit.
You know, she wanted to go there. I fucking took it there.
And that's what happened. I ate two cupcakes for breakfast.
What are you think about that?
It was sitting there leftover from the party and I said,
that's a great way to start my day.
Let me give myself 9,000 calories of straight sugar.
It was unreal. It was like I did an eight ball.
That's where ate the two cupcakes for 20 minutes.
I was just sitting there thinking, how fucking great I wasn't. I'm like,
I'm fucking awesome. I could do anything I want.
I'm fucking the greatest.
And 20 minutes later when the sugar started wearing off, oh my God.
I started pulling the drapes closed, laying in here like, uh, I dunno.
I Dunno. Don't ever start your day with fucking two, two cupcakes.
FTE had a beef.
She fucking Ravioli beef cheek. I was like, cheek like the ass.
You being cute. They're like, no, they actually know what,
I didn't have the fucking balls to ask him. I didn't want to know.
I was eating somebody's face meeting the Yech face. Yeah.
Let me get the Yak taint red goon. Um,
all right, let's continue with the, uh,
the continuing story of American Airlines. If you listened to my, uh,
my podcast last week, uh, these cheap ass motherfuckers at American Airlines,
uh, you know, they alligator armed the fucking right food up in first class.
You know what I mean?
They had 20 people in First Class and they made five onwards and next thing you
know I was eating a bowl of total open Nebraska. Actually, no,
that's not what happened. Steve, a quick synopsis. I said,
fuck you and your honeycomb cereal.
This is first class and I don't get a Goddamn Mama. I don't want anything.
I said all of that with a little less anger and no curses.
So a few seconds later the guy came back.
All of a sudden magically he has an outlet and I'm like, where did you get that?
And he informed me that the pilots said he already ate so I could have his
onwards. And I was like, I don't want his fucking Omelet. I want my omelet.
All right, I don't want to starving pilot. You know,
passing out up there, seeing bogeys leaning forward on the Goddamn yoke,
whatever you call it. All right.
So I sent them a letter and this is the letter that they sent back to me and I
swear to God, you know,
back in the day if something like this ever happened and you actually wrote a
letter you prefer at least they give you a free airline ticket. And I'm,
when I say back in the day, I mean like 2005, 2006.
Now they don't give a shit. They just keep apologizing profusely.
This is a dumb ass letter they sent back to me.
I'm only going to read you part of it because they just keep saying the same
thing over and over again. Okay. I think I got the hiccups.
Like I have sugar hiccups from stuffing down to cupcakes.
Hang on a second. Just from service. Hello? Yeah,
I'm going to check out about like 15 minutes. Okay.
Thank you Jesus. They didn't say anything. She said hello?
I said, yeah, I'm gonna check out 15 minutes.
At which point she could have said, okay. Or older overlay, you know.
But no, she just closes the door. All right. Okay.
Here's the fucking, uh, what do we got here? This is still here. This is,
this is the letter that American Airlines sent me. Okay, dear Mr Burr,
thank you for contacting American Airlines.
It's our privilege to respond to your message. Okay. First of all,
right there. They already pissed me off. Okay. Don't,
don't start with off with your fucking stock line.
Yeah.
Like your Jackie Gleason, you know, thank you for writing as in a way we go,
you know, a little shoving off the buffalo. Uh, okay.
I'm very sorry to hear of your disappointment with us and regret that you did
not receive your preferred entree when you traveled with us in the first class
cabin. Uh,
sales soul assists because we want your travel experience or improving premium
cabins to be truly something special.
We do our best to cater our entree selections so that we can serve each customer
the entree they prefer. This is the part which is just complete bullshit.
Okay. They want to make sure that they serve the entree that I prefer, you know,
and yeah, you can do that. Bringing up fucking eggs on the flight.
This is what they write to do.
So we determine which entrees are selected most often.
It's often and provision accordingly. That's,
that's such fucking bullshit.
But then they watched Jurassic Park when Jeff Goldbloom did his little rant
about chaos theory.
You think cause you'd take 10 flights or a hundred flights and you figure out,
oh you know, seven people want the Omelet
and you know, nine people want something else. That sucked. Bullshit.
First of all, nobody wants to fucking cereal.
Yeah,
no one wants cereal at first-class. Okay?
Okay,
you fucking dropped $1,500 or whatever the hell is 800 and $1,500 on tickets.
You want something [inaudible] substance. I'm sick of bitching about this.
Oh I know. It was in the end of it. I ended up flying fucking a middle seat.
The fucking Dallas and all I got was a $150 voucher,
which will pay for one third. They didn't give me anything Mr. Barrier.
We are not unmindful of the inconvenience of you. Well,
how the fuck would you be on Michael? I wrote your goddamn letter.
As hard as we are trying to deliver on respecting your time by operating our
flights as scheduled. It just wasn't possible this time. Again,
we apologize for the disruption of your travel plans. We're not giving you shit.
Please sly with us again soon.
We'll do our best to get you to your destination as planned.
Really, you're going to do your best. That's what you can give me.
American Airlines. Well, Gee, you know, we're going to try.
That's a comforting attitude to have when they're going to be flying the fucking
36,000 feet off the goddamn ground. Oh, do I sound like a camp this week?
So that's basically it. That's, that's the, uh,
the next level that they've taken it to where it used to be like, okay,
we fuck you over. And the stewardess gives you a hand job. You know,
that was 1975 and in the 80s, it was, you know,
we'll give you a free ticket and a skinny Michael J. Fox tie. But those things,
you know, when you had the little spiked out mullet and uh,
they had lasted for a good 20 years and uh,
somewhere in the last four or five years it became a,
we're going to fuck you over. Read back, go fuck yourself.
What do think about that? Go Fuck Yourself.
[inaudible]
299 other people on the plane that didn't fit in complaint. What do you do?
Take the train. It's going to take him nine days to get to New York.
Go Fuck Yourself. Do you know you're coming back? It's just eggs.
You know yourself know what? They got me over God damn barrel sons of bitches.
What am I going to do? Fly ATA, you know Nina fucking,
yeah,
I don't know what in a goddamn chicken from actually I think ATA recently went
out of business. You have a fly in airline and then you know, you're like, Eh,
you know, it was kind of weird flight. You know, there was a crack in the uh,
inner window. Okay. Actually that happened to me on ATA was one of the windows,
you know, they got like the, they got the, the double pane of glass,
they got the, the one on the outside,
the outside of the plane and then they have the one, uh, on the inside,
the extra level one.
And that one was cracked and I believe it was a little bit of water in there.
And I said to the, to the stewardess, I was like a woman,
there's a fucking crack in the God damn window over here.
I'm afraid I'm going to get sucked out once we get above 6,000 feet. She said,
it's like I felt kind of like glass.
No. So I didn't feel bad when they went out of business.
Now I kind of feel bad because now there's no, there's no other option.
I guess that's my interruption.
Do I sit there and I take it on American Airlines and they go, go fuck yourself.
All right, we're going to give you a brand muffin.
I hope you brought some water.
Or I fly another airline when their inner window is cracked and no one thinks
it's a concern.
Okay.
Tanner winters crack. Well that's, that's all we got. Two of them. Alright,
this podcast is just a cluster fuck. Um,
let's get to some podcast questions that I didn't even,
I didn't even have the time to fucking look at this week. Actually.
That's not true. I went to look at them and somebody,
I don't know what's going on with my, my space page.
I don't know if anybody else has had this problem, but, uh,
I ended up able to really add anybody for about a year. You know,
every couple of days they'll get about 45 requests, I'll accept them.
And then a day later I have 47 people taken off my page. And it's like,
really? We're all those people spammers. I don't know what's going on. So, uh,
I'm having somebody look at my account. The only question I can remember,
I can't even remember. It was something about fucking, uh,
you know, what movies do I find scary? Um, well, you know what,
if you turned my flight on American Airlines into a movie,
I would've found that fucking scary. Um, what movies do I find scary?
Anything that involves a crazy woman? Um,
I think
the scariest movies when I first got cable and the early eighties when I had a
tight jeans and a pony high tops that just met the bottom of my jeans and no one
complained because somehow you could get away with that back then. Um,
I remember the first Friday, the 13th, when Jason came up out of the lake,
that scared the shit out of me. And there was another one. Here's the,
here's one for you. Okay. I got a podcast question for you guys.
There was a movie I saw late night cable and I can't remember what the fuck it
was,
but it somehow there was somebody skating across the pond in slow motion with an
ax. And I believe for some reason the, uh,
the monster I'm picturing is, is from that. I know this isn't it,
but the picture of my mind is, uh,
what does that monster book where the wild things are?
I remember what those monsters look like in my memory.
That's what the monster look like. Skating across the fucking lake. Uh,
and I know it isn't that, but I know somebody, what do you, what am I,
14 listeners out there has to be a fucking horror or a film, uh,
whatever the, what do you call someone's really into horror films. Like d? Yeah,
exactly. A horror film. Fucking Dick. There was that one. And uh,
there was another one I was just thinking of and I just sat up and I can't
remember it. I'm getting an echo fucking age.
I literally just moved my brain a little bit. The thought just went away.
Wait a second. What the fuck was I just thinking? Let me lay back down.
Let me see what will come back to me. Okay. I was talking about, we've,
we gotta go back in time, you know, I was talking, okay.
The lake wild things are,
see the side of my brain works. It works linear. Once I go past the moment,
I can't go back. It's like a fucking traffic jam.
What the fuck was I trying to think of
that shit. I don't know. Oh, I got it. Bam. There we go. Um,
dark night of the scare crow. I like the old horror movies.
Okay. This is what,
you know what I don't like about new horror movies that they would,
that CGI shit, they,
they can do so much insane stuff with computers that they forgot how to build
suspense. The old ones they used, they used to build it up.
They used to build up the moment where the monster was going to jump out at you
because they had to because it was just a guy in a rubber fucking suit,
you know what I mean? But now that they could, they can, you know,
they can make it look like Godzilla's stepping on New York.
They forgot how to build, dispense.
That's what I don't like about fucking horror movies now. And that's a,
I think Japanese, I don't know,
everybody over in Asia seems to know how to fucking do that,
but nobody over here does. Even like the, like, like thrillers,
whatever the fuck that, whatever a goddamn thriller is like, take that,
that movie a perfect storm. They had that God damn big wave,
that's all they showed in the trailer.
So everybody goes out to run out and see it and then they don't develop any of
the goddamn characters because the point that I don't give a fuck about anybody
in the movie. So by the, by the end of the movie,
I'm actually praying for the wave.
I can't wait for them to kill George Clooney and Mark Walberg and all those
other guys cause I don't give a fuck about their characters.
Cause if they haven't done anything to make me give a fuck,
they just had a couple people speaking Boston accent and you stick them on a
tugboat and I'm supposed to give a shit.
They're going to die trying to get lobster. Um,
I'm just in a bad mood. I'm going to bet fucking mood today. I'm like,
you know what it is is to God and don't ever start your day with two fucking
cupcakes. It seems like such a great, you know, such a great idea, you know,
like, oh I'm eight years old. This is what you'd want to do.
But your parents never loved you, you know, and now I'm 39 and 51 weeks.
And finally the dream that I thought was going to happen,
you know, oh it did happen. And it just doesn't play out. Right. Oh my God.
How did I forget this shit?
I know why I forgot it cause I have fucking two cupcakes where the sugar and my
brain, I actually had a crazy week. How crazy was it bill?
Um, I flew into New York on Wednesday. I did opie and Anthony Opening,
Anthony Ob and Anthony show Thursday morning.
Then I did my show at Caroline's in New York Thursday night.
I got up Friday morning, got on a plane, flew back to la.
I did the guys' choice awards on a spike TV,
men, all these famous people. They were all cool. I had a great time.
I met Nikki six I was way more thrilled and the after party was at the fucking
playboy mansion. And I know what you're thinking. Oh my God.
Playboy fucking mansion. That must have been unbelievable. Um,
I quickly realized when I got there,
there's two kinds of parties at the playboy mansion.
There's the your famous and you can come by Wednesday afternoon and actually
meet the broads that are in the magazine.
And then there's the one that I went to where it's like, yeah,
why don't you guys all just stand on my, in my backyard?
I literally thought I was going to show up to the mansion. Right.
It was going to be like me and eight other people and just, you know,
for playboy bunnies eats just rubbing on my chest. Hey man, you're a big boy.
I heard your comedian now. They just had, they had the,
it was definitely the beat team of Playboy bunny. You know,
they had the little bunny suits on the rabbit ears,
but let me tell you something. They were, uh,
they would grade a hooter girls and he could tell there was three of them who
were clearly being paid to frolic in the pool.
And any girl with bunny ears had like nine guys around her was a fucking sausage
fest. And this is the funny thing. Nobody was hitting on them.
They was standing there with the fucking cameras out,
taking pictures like, uh,
like they were Disneyland and they ran into Donald Duck or something.
It was pathetic. And uh, you know,
you have no was roped off with his three fucking girlfriends,
83 years old man guy. It was the shit that was the only thing I wanted to do.
I just want to go in there and shake his hand and uh,
then immediately stick my hand in bleach to get the unbelievable smell of 50
years of pussy off of my hand. And uh, then fly back.
But he was busy. I understand. He had to meet a famous fucking people.
So, uh, but still still shit. And then I flew back the next day,
six in the fucking morning, I landed in New York at about four 30. I got my bag,
I went over to Caroline's and I did three fucking shows, you know,
and then I went out drinking afterwards.
And that's the kind of thing that leads you to be in a cunty mood on a Tuesday
morning. You know, I did all of that and then I ate two cupcakes. All right,
so don't even question my fucking moved. All right. So, um,
so there you go. That was my week. Went to a party at the playboy mansion.
I could stand up on my first award show. When is it going to be at you ask why.
I'll tell ya it's gonna be on our June 22nd. Um,
and I had a great time doing the set even though, uh,
most of the crowd was a pay crowd, you know, good looking people,
hot chicks texting each other and I god,
like when is this going to be out bar?
It's like get GoLive I want to blow Jeremy Pip and I'm going to be on June 22nd
and this week coming up this week I'm going to be at a good night's comedy club
in Raleigh, North Carolina. You can go to bill,
burn.com and get all the fucking information. And uh, later on this month,
I'm going to be the punch line in Atlanta, Atlanta, the brothers call it,
and a, I think that date is June 19th or something like that.
I don't fucking know.
I can't get on this hotel internet and I have to check out in 19 fucking
minutes. So I gotta go apologize for, uh,
the podcast being a day late and, uh, forgive my continuous on this podcast.
I'm going to blame it on the sugar from the two cupcakes.
What a fucking half a fag, Huh? Starts the day with two cupcakes.
So they'd call me Billy two cupcakes. Billy cupcake. All right,
you guys have a good week. Please keep the podcast questions,
comments are about this week, man. I had some,
I don't know what's going on with my fucking page or please keep him calm and,
and, uh,
let people know about my podcast and thanks to everybody came out to my shows in
May in Philadelphia, Chicago and uh, in New York City.
All right, you guys all have a good week. I'll talk to you later. Bye.
[inaudible] I was trapped in the city one day. Everybody was
[inaudible]
[inaudible].